what happens next
the answer to that question has not felt
this uncertain for a long time because
it has truly been a tumultuous a frankly
at times shocking uh period in Tech over
the last few weeks it feels as if
decades have passed in mere days
and I want to start by reflecting that
and talking about that uh with the most
brilliant panel we have uh over here
Corey Dr o uh one of um the generations
great science fiction writers a blogger
and activist
um I'm not someone who knows your
software a long time ago he founded a
peer-to-peer networking company we also
have uh amber Gara a Serial web free
entrepreneur what does web3 mean well
we'll talk about that later
um and also exec chair at decentralized
the first uh in real life and metaverse
Music Festival
and hopefully behind us in the script
it's working in the screen we have Chris
Kelly uh and now an investor who was the
25th employee at Facebook as it was
known then where he was head of privacy
so a really fantastic panel to discuss
this question what comes next
I want to ask to start by asking you all
the same question
in the last few weeks what has surprised
or shocked you most of all the things
that have happened what has truly
surprised you Chris what about you what
what was it completely unexpected of all
the things that have happened
I I mean I think that the the radical
change inside Twitter is probably the
biggest surprise of of the of the week
um and the fact that it would go from uh
you know it's a central Town Square for
the world to you know will it work
tomorrow
um it's a pretty big
um you know set of questions and and I
you know I think it probably will
certainly work tomorrow I think it's
still going to be uh an impressive Town
Square for the world but the the massive
cutbacks and the sort of Chainsaw that
that Elon Musk has taken to the company
um it doesn't bode well for its future
and and I think that that's a huge
surprise
especially journalists
um so so because you're you're a Silicon
Valley Insider really
um you I think invested early on in
SpaceX you knew who Elon Musk was
but you were surprised by what's
happened
I I mean I think that that
he should have taken a much more
measured approach to uh to the way that
the company was taken over and in a
variety of ways I mean look I I I as I
said you know publicly or I I'm mostly
an Elon fan
um he's able to do some pretty amazing
things but he's gotten into an area
that's well outside his depth and um you
know and and thinks that that a a kind
of bullying management culture uh can
change it and and that's and that's just
not working right now and it's not going
to work
um at a Twitter
um you know I I guess I I would hope
that somebody who um you know has has
had such amazing success in other areas
would take uh a more measured approach
and that just hasn't happened so that
that's why I'm surprised by it I mean
I've certainly seen some some driving
management moves uh from Elon at Tesla
and SpaceX before but um I'm surprised
that that this that this was the
approach okay thank you um Amber what
about you what's surprised you I mean
you must have been pretty shocked when
FDX
for those who don't know FTX is a
cryptocurrency Exchange
a a little like a a bank this is not a
good analogy but a little like a bank
for cryptocurrencies why do
cryptocurrencies which are meant to be
totally decentralized have things like
Banks
why indeed but anyway this this entity
completely has completely imploded in
the most dramatic fashion in the last
few weeks and with someone who works in
this space
I mean I was shocked you must have been
stunned
well to be honest this story started
back in May of last year when we started
having a the one of the cryptocurrencies
algorithmic stable coins supposedly that
failed and it showed that the
centralized decentralized Finance system
is very fragile and very weak and it
showed basically that there was a huge
contamination in the space back in May
and we were expecting to see more
fiascos coming coming through I must say
I was surprised that FTX went bankrupt
for the simple reason that I would have
assumed so I'm I spent my career in
Investment Banking the founder as well
so yeah you were you were at JP Morgan I
think yeah you you know this space so
you know that say
um taking billions of money from people
and then giving it to an investment
vehicle to put into more crypto projects
and keeping no liability keeping no
money for yourself
probably not a good idea right it is the
you know what is really really
frustrating for me and other people in
this space is that what we saw in crypto
especially in centralized decentralized
Finance is that people are making the
same mistakes that have led to the
financial crisis of 2008. like the same
mistake it's like you did not learn for
the mistake of your older brothers and
all and older sisters and what we saw in
FTX and in other uh in other lenders cd5
lenders is that there's no counterparty
risk management no risk management no
internal controls and basically if the
regulation that were created after the
financial crisis of 2008 to limit the
power of the banks the power of the
hedge fund and create more transparency
in the system were applied to this these
crypto companies we would have had maybe
would have had the same Fiasco but it
would have been less less shocking than
what we're seeing today so just just
really quickly then you're a web 3
entrepreneur and you want regulation I
want regulations yes I want smart
regulation but I want regulation yes
okay thanks yeah Corey Corey what about
you I mean on one level right
is any of this surprising uh Elon Musk
has behaved like Elon Musk
um a completely unregulated space has
gone kaput
you've been you know prominent and uh
you know very strong critic of big Tech
and crypto over the years
were you were you surprised were you
were you all the same were you shocked
at what just happened so I I think that
big tax uh hype machine wants us to
think that they're Evil Geniuses they
want us to think that they've figured
out how to hack our dopamine loops and
make uh uh addictive technology but when
you look really closely at what they do
they just have monopolies right what
they've got is like a platform that they
got all your uh the people that you love
and care about and want to transact with
or go on a date with and they've locked
them into a silo that whenever anyone
tries to build technology that lets
people out of The Silo you know when
when Facebook started it had a little
bot that you could give your login and
password to it would go to Myspace and
get your waiting messages and put them
in your Facebook inbox and you can reply
to them and push them back out to
Myspace so you didn't have to choose
between the people you loved who are on
MySpace and the uh service that was
better which was on Facebook you could
get both and today if you try to do that
to Facebook or or Apple or Google they
just reduce you to Radioactive rubble
and so you know what they've done is use
access to the Capital markets to build
these big impregnable silos to buy
everyone who wants to compete with them
Mark Zuckerberg gets up in the middle of
the night and sends an email to a CFO
saying young people hate Facebook they
like Instagram we have to buy Instagram
because quote it is better to buy than
to compete right this is the kind of
thing you absolutely don't want to put
in writing it's like saying let's do a
murder and premeditate it and make sure
that we premeditate it because we know
Murder is wrong right it's just not
something you want to write down and
it's probably not a coincidence couple
hours later he sent a very wooden
follow-up email presumably after a angry
phone call from his general counsel that
said for avoidance of doubt I think
competition is great and I only want to
buy Instagram because I think they will
benefit and we will benefit from it and
we will produce synergies really what he
wants to do is keep you hostage so the
thing about these services that are
based on hostage taking Mutual hostage
taking I'm they're holding you hostage
you're there holding me hostage is that
hypothetically they can unwind as fast
as they wound up right if the reason
you're there is that someone you love is
there and that person leaves then it's
easier for you to go this switching
costs leave and so you know we've seen
these very precipitous declines
Friendster Myspace six degrees you know
here one day gone the next the founder
of our Feast today Rupert Murdoch uh
turned a lot of money into a very small
amount of money by buying Myspace the
way that Elon Musk is on track to doing
with although on but on the recent
events I feel like
the thing that surprised me was how
quickly this thing that we knew could
happen but which it seemed like the laws
of gravity had been suspended for a
decade and it seems like very quickly
people are going I don't need Twitter
and Facebook as much as I used to think
I needed them and now that the people I
love are leaving maybe I won't spend as
much time you know I know that that
Twitter uh views are up but I think
they're up in the same way that like
people crowding around a burning
building to watch it go down uh that
building is seeing more footfall it's
not really the same thing as your
business increasing okay right I wanna
Chris I want to bring in Chris here
um you know Mark Zuckerberg right but
just right just before I do that a
reminder that you can pose questions to
our brilliant panel by scanning the QR
code on your seat or if you're watching
on TV
um submit your questions on Twitter
using the hashtag Big Ideas live22
Chris you know Mark Zuckerberg
um Evil Genius
um uh out of his depth Man Child uh
monopolists
um yeah how would you how would you
characterize him
so look so much of this is a battle for
attention and that is competition in a
number of different ways it's a it's a
battle for how do you get users to
actually pay attention to your platform
and use it to communicate with others
and and there are a number of different
platforms that that have deep sets of
information on that in IOS and Android
and Facebook and Instagram and you know
in in quite a number of different ones
the the control by phone companies and
and and other you know companies that
compete with each other for user
attention over time so I as a trained
antitrust lawyer I represented you know
Netscape against Microsoft I've I've
been in this and certainly from a
traditional definition of an antitrust
law there aren't monopolies here in a
lot of different places there are
bottleneck controls in things like iOS
um you know I think at one point maybe
you could have argued that Facebook you
know had that type of control over
people in certain jurisdictions in
Canada or in the US but they certainly
don't now and so it's a it is the sort
of War of all against all going on in
technology and I and I think ultimately
that's competition I do think it's
pretty stunning how fast these things
can unravel and that's one of the things
that that I think that this Twitter
situation shows this week um is that you
can you can kind of step on this in a
number of different ways you know not
not quite accidentally but you don't
want to mess with it
um you know as as precipitously as Elon
has with Twitter thanks but because I
it's raised a really interesting point
here you know I opened the panel by
saying the future felt incredibly
uncertain
but look if we've got a bunch of
monopolies that are very hard to escape
from is anything really going to change
Chris in a strange way I feel like
you're saying that things could change
competing with each other that's not a
monopoly
okay so in a way so you're saying that
you do see the possibility for quite
extensive change ahead
oh absolutely uh I think that there's
there's there's robust and wide open
competition for user attention among
different media networks and I think
that that's pretty exciting
and Corey yeah because because what do
you think about that because because I
are you saying that
the three side of this which I which I
think is is also quite fascinating and
the in the number of different networks
that you you're seeing Mastodon and and
post and quite a number of these
networks bring up as Twitter has its
problems
so yeah so go on Corey and then I want
to bring in Amber on web three yeah just
to see rice Chris I mean I I think that
there's some um uncertainty about terms
here and so uh we heard that from a
traditional uh antitrust perspective we
don't have monopolies the tradition that
that that that that uh is referring to
is a 40 year old tradition uh it's the
it's the consumer welfare tradition that
was brought in by Thatcher Reagan
Mulroney in Canada where I'm from and it
represented a complete break with the
century of antitrust law before the
first antitrust law in the United States
was passed by Senator Robert Sherman in
1890 and he was very clear that the
problem with firms was not whether they
competed or not it was whether they
exercise power over your life he stood
on the floor of the Senate and he said
if we would not allow a king to rule
over us I had to take a note of loyalty
when I became a British citizen but I
don't think we should have a king to
rule over us if we would not allow a
king to rule over us we should not allow
an autocrat of trade to rule over us
either that when firms are able to uh
even though there are competing among
each other to see who can abuse you in
the most novel way when there isn't
sufficient competition that you can
arrange a non-abusive relationship like
apple for example if you opt out of all
Apple tracking you may have seen those
ads iPhone means privacy that are all
over the place you opt out of all Apple
tracking Apple still tracks every tap
you make everywhere you go with all the
accelerometer data your IP address from
place to place all of your location data
everything you open all of that is still
tracked but they don't sell it to anyone
else they just use it to Target you for
ads they call that privacy right so what
is the where does where is the
competition I'm on Google and apple you
can get any flavor so long as it's
orwellian right well what if you want
not Orwell flavored that that's much
harder to come by okay so but Corey just
to pick you up on this right I you
that's fascinating right now the
development of this in the web three
so but yeah
um so Corey uh just to pick you up on
this you said that people are leaving
Twitter in droves yeah
I mean but you can't facing the point
that you can't really leave a monopoly
how does this work well so they're
leaving Twitter and droves but they're
still uh keeping one foot in because
it's very hard to get away from it um
what they're mostly doing is they're
abandoning the relationships that they
had so many of you will have seen that
that musical Fiddler on the Roof if you
haven't I'm about to spoil a 60 year old
musical for you uh that it's a musical
about people who live in a shadow in
Poland and it life is bad and it gets
steadily worse but they can't leave
because they love each other and if they
go anywhere else they will be broken up
and they'll lose each other forever
after uh things reach a kind of fever
pitch again spoiler alert they all leave
the village becomes a ghost town and
they go to lots of different places and
they lose each other right there's it's
a very funny poignancy and I'm going to
Chicago I'm going to New York why are
you going to Chicago my brother-in-law
lives there oh that'll be nice no I
don't like him but family is family it's
a great scene good good good good
musical if you get a chance to see it
but the lesson here is that uh if you
cannot bring your community with you
when you go somewhere else
the fact that whether we call this a
monopoly or Market power or a market
failure doesn't really matter we all
understand that what it is is it's
excessive corporate power that adversely
affects us in our daily lives in
important ways and that these are not
like the great forces of History bearing
down on this moment to create that
excessive Market power it was
forbearance for mergers predatory
pricing predatory Acquisitions conduct
that was historically prohibited under
competition law in the EU in the UK and
in the U.S and that for 40 years we
pretended wasn't in the law books and
what's happening now is there's a shift
we have the digital markets act and epu
and so on
um so I'm right where so web three may I
just jump on on a couple of points yeah
because tell me what you think about
this because web3 in a sense the
marketing at least it was designed to
solve this exact problem can it do that
so just let me just go back on the other
point please so I just want to look at
it more from an economical perspective
of what is Big Tech facing today so
there's the current economic environment
there's the requirement from users for
more data privacy and then there's
competition from new entrants targeting
gen Zed and gen Alpha but I'm talking
about the economic environment what does
that mean I'm taking you back to 2008 so
in 2008 we had this huge financial
crisis that led central banks into a
quantitative easing and bringing rates
to zero so you had tons of money on the
floor or in the market that money was
supposed to trickle down into the
economy to create activity and create
consumer inflation it never happened
what we saw is that that money started
flooding into Venture Capital firm
private Equity Firm and and public
equities and so we were in a situation
where money was so cheap and it was so
easy to vest that we created this asset
this inflation and asset prices an asset
bubble literally a lot of it went into
Bitcoin it was small Tech at the time
medium Tech a lot of it went into into
tech companies the investors did not
care much about the basic of Finance
looking at a bottom line looking at
profitability the investors cared about
growth everyone was talking about growth
generate more growth have more users
have more revenues no one thinking about
the bottom line where are we today we
have rates that are up we have central
banks that are actually tightening so
access to money is actually more
difficult and suddenly now investors are
telling themselves hold on a second I
need to start looking at my bottom line
I want to invest in companies that are
actually profitable and so this
psychology of revenues at any cost is
starting to escape from the market where
does this leave big Tech so big Tech has
been used to crazy valuation has been
used to a lot of cash spending a lot of
cash on hiring a lot of employees on
projects that worked or didn't work
today they need to restructure they need
to start focusing on the bottom line and
this is they've been hit quite hardly
and this is why in terms of stock prices
they are the ones that have decreased
the most and so in certain practical
terms then does this mean that
essentially what we what we're going to
get is the same
but maybe a bit less luxurious or is
there a technological Revolution coming
along which can actually answer the Deep
rooted questions that say Corey's been
raising for instance that you can't take
your friends with you when you leave
Twitter so there there is a disruption
in the way and we're still at the very
very early stages of it and we're all
making mistake and stumbling and sending
back again to build that what we call
that web 3 space but before talking
about web 3 maybe it's good to take a
step back and try to understand where
web1 web 2 web 3 position themselves
versus one another so back in the 90s
web one was fully decentralized it was
free anyone could host a server any one
could use a computer to relay messages
between a servers and a browser so you
started having people building
application on the internet but in order
for this application to be able to
communicate with one another to be able
to become more scalable we started
inventing standards so one of the
easiest standards to understand that I'm
sure everyone knows here is HTML it's
your web page right you could use any
browser to read a web page that browser
could be called Netscape Firefox Chrome
etc etc
but the flip side of this
standardization was that as Corey said
user could take their data and move
anywhere they wanted move through the
platform and so big Tech who were still
small Tech at the time were like all
right I need to keep my users locked in
so they started creating standardization
for their own application to lock in the
users why did they need to lock in the
users because we were during the
internet boom and there was a lot of
money as well flooding into these
companies and what people were thinking
about is number of users they didn't
care yet about how to monetize these
users what they cared about is having an
increase in number of users and then
suddenly these companies whether
investors were telling them guys we need
to generate revenues now all right how
do I generate revenues at the time none
of us huh advertising at yeah you you
you assemble a community let me let me
sell them ads advertisements that's the
model right hold on because there's a
justification for advertising at the
time no one would have accepted to use a
credit card they were talking about two
thousand to use a credit card to pay for
a subscription on the internet that was
like super risky and so the product had
to stay free you needed the product to
stay free and so these companies were
like all right I have this a lot of data
here I have the behaviors of my of my
users let's go for advertising and this
is how big Tech started becoming very
slowed and or big Tech Web 2.0 basically
started becoming very slowed and focused
on Data Tracking and and data selling
now during this period of time in the
early 2000s something very important
happened there was a um an application
that was called naps sister does anyone
remember an app store here okay yeah so
well but Napster was a free music
service yes but it was a centralized
music uh sharing system technology yeah
and so Napster because of the drummer of
Metallica Napster was sued for copyright
infringement and Napster got shut down
and this what about what we call the
gluta LA protocol which was the first
decentralized peer-to-peer file sharing
system right and that was the basic or
that was the fundament in my opinion to
what would be called become Bitcoin at a
later stage
become web three because I think because
I think the question is is that are we
going to see truly decentralized
services that actually have a truly
different business model to Big Tech in
the way that for instance Napster had a
truly different model than say whatever
a place iTunes Apple music that actually
replaced it uh Chris you're an investor
in this space
look it's right right now web three yeah
sorry I'm sorry yeah go ahead
yes you know it's very real and it it
eventually you know replaced iTunes
eventually replaced Napster but it took
quite some time and and they're
inevitably going to be a number of of
centralization points um where
standardization happens
um I think that web 3 and particularly
with you know the the you know
expectation of public blockchains being
the basis for uh for a lot of the
operations means that decentralization
can be relatively well protected over
time
um there are battles over privacy uh in
that space inevitably about if is one of
you know one of the great powers of the
blockchain is is it's is it's mostly
public nature
um but you still want a number of things
for people to to maintain privacy around
and and sometimes centralization Springs
up to to to feed that need and sometimes
centralization is then you know abused
in a number of different ways as it has
been in FTX and and in some of the other
kind of you know exchange uh collapses
over time
but the fundamental idea of a
cryptographically provable trustless
technology underpinning a lot of this
space I think is an incredibly powerful
idea which will come to the fore
continue to come to the fore over the
next five to ten years and and
ultimately be the basis for uh so many
of these systems we are heading back
towards a more decentralized internet
um in that way uh Corey your thoughts I
am well so I think that there are
elements of of sort of blockchain
ideology that are decentralized
um I think that you know when you build
a a new internet based on the idea that
you solve problems with creating markets
and everything and then the speculators
uh Gamble that they can make those
markets and create uh and extract value
from those markets by being the
exchanges or by holding a a plurality of
the tokens or what have you you do
create some decentralization what but
what I'm afraid of is that our all
evidence has been that the decentralized
is the decentralization you create is
you still are in a world run by you know
25 billionaires but now they have a
thousand Banks to hold their money in
and that is more decentralized than 25
billionaires holding hiding all their
money in four Banks well what it hasn't
done is decentralize power
and that's the most important thing here
so whether we're talking about proof of
work or proof of stake
um to a lesser extent uh the the uh
cryptographically secure protocols that
use secure enclaves
um you are still ultimately producing
winner take all economies where you have
increasing concentration of wealth into
a few hands and so what that means is
that wherever you try to make a decision
that reflects the the uh uh will of the
polity and things that are good for the
polity it always has to be measured
against the outsized influence of people
who can buy a lot of power we see that
in the real world and we see it in the
virtual worlds that
um it's uh it's very hard to make
evidence-based policies you say we want
good policy it's very hard to make good
policy when there are people who can
just sort of Bigfoot good policy with uh
very expensive AstroTurf campaigns you
know like um what we saw during the
passage of the gdpr and subsequently
during the enforcement where the firms
involved just keep saying the Privacy is
not something we should have and if we
have a law for it it shouldn't be
enforced okay I mean gdpi did eventually
pass um Amber uh I still I saw you
nodding during that but count can web 3
whatever it is if if it's created can it
escape the Trap of centralization or the
difficulty of centralization is there is
it realistic to think about a
decentralized future and why would we
actually want that I mean this is why
we're working every day are we there yet
definitely not
nothing is decentralized purely
decentralized yet and one thing Corey
has highlighted very very correctly is
that a lot of these blockchains and a
lot of these Protocols are actually very
centralized in the way they are governed
so they are governed based on the amount
of money that you have in the protocol
your vote is equal to the amount of
money you have in the protocol so where
is the voice of the little people that
were supposed to to here still not here
so look you know we're all nerds on this
stage right and we love debating
centralization and decentralization
exactly you know the fine details
between them but to everyone out here
why why should they really care about
decentralization when let's be honest
it's the most decentralized platforms
are harder to use
fully agree what's your elevator picture
to everyone in terms of decentralization
the appeal of it well
so two things or actually one thing when
we had web tool the user became the
product the product was free the user
became the product with web 3 including
blockchains and blockchain protocols
what we want to do is let the user
become the owner of the product and this
is what we're working we're working
towards and do you think people really
care about that because I feel like that
the the surprise you'd be surprised how
much people now care about big entities
controlling their data controlling the
information
why do you think why do you think Apple
decided to stop or to allow its users to
opt out they smelled the fire before
anyone else smelled it and they decided
to allow their user to opt out and have
this label of privacy friendly so yes
users do care about that especially the
Gen Zed and and gen Alpha and you'd be
surprised okay we'd love to hear your
thoughts on this reminder you can submit
questions by if you're in the room by
scanning the QR codes that should be on
your seats or if you're watching online
or on TV please let us know do you do
people actually care about privacy
enough to sacrifice user convenience use
the hashtag Big Ideas live um so Chris
first I saw you nodding and then Corey
we've got a lot to get through so let's
go briefly the idea that there doesn't
have to be a trade-off over time and and
this is one of the areas where having
development based on open protocols
um can be incredibly powerful is that
you can build systems that aren't
entirely centralized that that you have
a lot of control over historically you
know because of the economic incentives
are are there to you know control them
and then and then manipulate them in
some ways and you can whether you or not
you think that that's what Facebook has
done or what apple is doing right now or
what Google does with Android
um those economic incentives are all
there
um to to pursue very deeply if you start
again from a a blockchain based approach
you have technical problems for for a
while both then you know you know
initial confusion and a lack of
understanding about how to get
everything to talk to each other
um you have you know coordination
problems in that you know there's not
necessarily traditional kind of
corporate organization focused on how do
you build a company around this but
you've seen amazing things jump up in in
both in real decentralized finance and
automated market makers and and things
like that
um with uniswap and other protocols
um you you but you also see a lot of you
know manipulation and and over time and
that gets called out in a public way
because the way that most blockchains
work
um and then it gets it gets abused in a
number of different ways as we've seen
in the Luna Fiasco and now in FTX
um the fact that all of these things are
coming to the foreign quickly I think is
a powerful thing for uh blockchain based
and web3 based Technologies over time
and I and I think that you'll see just
as TCP kind of came to the fore just as
HTML came to the fore over time you know
you'll see a lot of standardization on
on web3 and blockchain Technologies
Empower amazing businesses and social
projects that um that allow people to
have more control over their data okay
thanks yeah I mean because so just to
translate to anyone wondering that
TCP for instance is the one of the
founding Protocols of the entire web and
it is truly truly truly it's the way the
computers talk to each other yeah thank
you is they uh it's the way the
computers talk to each other and these
are open platforms open platforms have
been incredibly successful you might not
know it but you probably use open source
software every single day
however that open source software has
often been Incorporated by a company
that is owned by shareholders or just by
one man say for instance Elon Musk and
so is it really open
Corey because I want to get your view in
this because you've actually been
involved in this movement since the very
beginning you've got the perspective
tell us briefly again please yeah I
think it's real I think the important
way to understand whether you are the
product or whether you're the customer
is not about the business model it's
about power
firms will treat you as their
inconvenient gut Flora for you know an
immortal Colony organism called a
limited liability company if they can so
the thing that determines whether or not
a firm abuses you is whether it's
disciplined by regulators and whether
it's disciplined by competitors some mix
of those two is what causes firms to
behave well it's not that some firms are
made up of good people and some firms
are made up of bad people companies
don't have personalities right I live a
a mile away from the gates of the of the
Disney Studios and for years and years
there was this story that um you had Fox
that had one ideology and you had Disney
that had a completely different ideology
and ideologically they could never come
together and then Rupert Murdoch flogged
Fox to Disney right so either were made
to believe that Murdoch and Bob Iger
were star-crossed lovers making google
eyes at each other across the table at
Davos for years or maybe there was no
ideology ideological difference between
them maybe be all the stuff about
whether Bart Simpson can tell a fart
joke and Mickey Mouse can't is just uh
window dressing yeah
decentralization though yeah so whether
apple is going to respect your privacy
has to do more with whether they can get
away with invading it not with their
with their personality so just to
summarize that because I feel like what
you're what you're saying very simply is
there is no technological solution to
the question of power it has to be done
by by regulation so we can't just
decentralize everything and work it all
out so for so Tech computers are amazing
computers uh every computer can run all
the software we know how to run that's
the only computer we know how to make
the touring complete Von Neumann machine
that means that you can always desilo
data you can plug something into
Facebook or Twitter any decentralized
services and allow people to leave what
stops people from doing that is not the
technical challenge it's the fact that
there's laws that these firms can deploy
to punish you if you reverse engineer
their code if you violate their terms of
service if you do the things that these
firms did to all of their rivals on the
way up when they did it that was
progress when you do it it's theft uh
and so you know there is a regulatory
barrier there's also the potential for a
regulatory age so in the European Union
they're mandating that companies
decentralized they're saying that you
must allow third parties to connect your
service through the digital markets act
so there's lots of different ways that
we can decentralize it but unless we're
focusing on power
right and not uh how many servers there
are how many lines of code there are how
many Bitcoins there are floating out
there but how the power works and how
the power is concentrated the
decentralization comes to nothing okay
right we've so we've got just a couple
of minutes until we have questions
reminder please submit your questions so
that I want to do a bit of a of a
lightning Round Here sure um just to get
your views on some topics at the moment
um Chris um very briefly very very
briefly metaverse Mark Zuckerberg's
dream of the metabus real or rubbish
uh it's it's real but not in the uh
near-term framework okay
are you do you believe in the metaverse
I do believe in the metaverse but again
we're very early
it's clunky it's very ugly still but the
metaverse for Facebook I would say it is
his pivot if he gets it right he saves
the company if he gets it wrong I think
Facebook is going to be in a lot of
trouble okay to those for those of you
who don't know Mark Zuckerberg has
invested I think it is 36 billion
dollars in his dream of a virtual
reality world the metaverse and so far
produced
I mean like not a lot so it's very
expensive bet he's bet he's betting the
whole company on it Corey yes or no do
you believe that we will have a
metaverse I I think that's nonsense I
think it was created to distract us from
Mark Zuckerberg's inability to have a
second good idea uh and he he
um and so he's just uh trying to conjure
something into existence he's done this
once before you remember the pivot to
video where he convinced every media
company in the world to waste billions
by lying to them about how many videos
people were watching now he's doing it
by lying about the fact that we all want
to be legless low polygon cartoon
characters okay uh but it's the it all
amounts to the same thing now so thank
you say it second lightning question uh
Chris will Twitter exist in a year yes
or no Twitter the the platform the
service yes
but it may be a shell of its former self
okay I I agree the subscript the new
subscription model is not gonna please a
lot of people around
so so you think it will exist but people
won't be happy with it what exists but
you will have less users okay story you
yeah the future compost the past it's
not going away you know you can still
get a live Journal account of course
we'll still have Twitter whether or not
it matters is the important question
okay and then the final question
um I want you to put a number on this in
terms of years how many years
will it be until we see some until we
see something that looks like web3 Chris
uh I mean I think we're seeing it right
now it's it's the classic you know Bruce
Sterling line it's like the features
already here it's just unevenly
distributed okay so Zero from Chris uh
amber you so it has started a long time
ago it's becoming more popular now but
again there's inter operability
clunkiness fragmentation so I would say
between five to ten years to get to get
where we want to be okay so I've got to
be honest it feels like web three is 90
scams and maybe 10 interesting
Innovation but I guess to scale I
completely agree with that yeah yeah
okay yeah so um Corey what about you you
know I'm with William Gibson who said
the future is here it's not evenly
distributed he thinks web 3 is nonsense
oh sorry you got it right yeah
so you know I I think that um it's uh
not gonna happen the way that they say
it is I think that uh uh it's again it's
just a kind of distraction from what's
what's really going on in Tech which is
uh a techlash and I don't think you
create correct that techlash by adding a
transaction layer also as a computer
scientist I just find blockchain to be
the most unforgivable nonsense the idea
that we would voluntarily do computation
that we can't reverse later that is
permanently etched in The Ledger and
then put billions of dollars into it in
case if we made a bug that bug can be
exploited forever and then our fix to
this is to give random authorities the
ability to rewrite that code that was
not supposed to be rewritable it's a
it's nonsense built on nonsense built on
stilts wrapped in a soft flowery
tortilla
and on that bombshell claim before we
get into this the complex topic of
Bitcoin of blockchains let's take some
questions um I've got a question here
from Jeff White Jeff are you are you in
the audience
stand up and wait for the mic to come
over and tell us your question
it's it's coming to you from yeah from
behind
thanks it's a really great panel um I've
been watching like a lot of people sort
of rolling skip fire of the FTX
cryptocurrency exchange
um and as Amber's pointed out the the
tether stable coin turned out to be
anything but stable and yet we still
have governments talking admittedly just
talking at the moment about introducing
National cryptocurrencies and we have
countries some some of them have
recognized crypto as legal tender and
those two things seem to lead in
different directions I just wonder what
the panel think of government
cryptocurrency in the future
yes sorry currencies I'll pick up that
one so there's uh two things people
sometimes forget uh cbdc in my opinion
in the UK not a lot of sense we have
faster payment yeah we can transfer
money from bank account in Split seconds
in the US it makes sense because the U.S
payment infrastructure is very
Antiquated it dates from the 60s if you
want to transfer from a local bank money
from a local Bank in one state to
another state it take it it can take up
to five days for the US makes sense for
the UK not really okay yeah I I think
that we have to distinguish between
central bank digital currencies which
are not cryptocurrency it's just giving
everyone an account at the fed or at
these Checker and and the one country as
far as I know that's trying to accept uh
crypto as legal tender which is the
melting down economy of El Salvador that
is in absolute shambles and tatters so I
don't know that I would I would call
that a a counter example I think that uh
it's actually just an example right
don't do like stop doing that No One's
Gonna No One's Gonna Go give me more of
what Kelly's doing although although we
will see Jeff because I think one
interesting aspect of national
cryptocurrencies is that it would allow
a government saying authoritarian state
to track it absolutely my detail
although again those aren't
cryptocurrencies they're just digital
currencies they're not in an immutable
decentralized Ledger it's just a
spreadsheet at the central bank this is
very true right so it's not a
cryptocurrency in any sense so let's get
another question I think Melanie's in
the audience has got a question
ah there you are thanks if you could
just wait for the mic to come around
there you go
thank you okay so I was wondering to
what extent do you think the spread of
fake news and increasing political
polarization has contributed to the loss
of users from platforms such as Twitter
and how can this be combat it sorry so
Chris did you hear that the this this
was about to what extent has the spread
of fake news and misinformation
contributed to disillusionment in in big
Tech
I mean I I I do think that it continues
to be a significant problem and it was
one of those things that that um you
know the the Elon I think showed a
particular lack of understanding of as
he began the Twitter discussion and
takeover and has shown more
misunderstanding of uh ever since and
and I think that that you know that you
have to be policing at the margins
um you know misinformation on platforms
while allowing a wide berth of free
speech
um these are complicated and nuanced
issues at the end of the day which is
why so much time and effort inside these
platforms is is invested in it
um the fact that it's become a a public
political football in both U.S and World
politics is another complicating Factor
but it doesn't mean that the the
companies can't do it or shouldn't do it
um and I think that that you know I
think you've seen the the Twitter
ability to do that you know fairly
quickly decimate did and I don't think
that I think that's one of the things
that's going to make the platform
difficult to you know be as important as
it once was I'm
very early you were Global legal council
I think it was effectively the head
lawyer I mean how much of a role did did
questions of Truth and misinformation
and disinformation play in the
discussions while you were there
we we had to deal with them all the time
I mean we saw the the initial aspects of
misinformation campaigns sort of being
built around elections
um as early as 2000 and
2006 and 2008 um we we had actually done
a number of projects to try to increase
Civic engagement on the platform
um at that time and we certainly saw
people try to use misinformation to
manipulate elections
um early on at that phase and and fought
against it hang on I'm sorry I've just
got to pick this up because Chris you
said that you saw manipulation of
Elections from 2006 but Mark Zuckerberg
has admitted that he didn't really take
this seriously until 2016. I mean what
happened in the interviewing 10 years
the scale the scale the scale changed
and uh and there were quite a number of
of folks who had I I had left at that
point um actually to you know to to uh
engage in politics on my own
um and and but we we had definitely seen
um some attempts at electoral
misinformation in the earlier races okay
thank you fascinating I just want to get
I'm sorry guys I just want to get one
more question because I think we've got
a really interesting one from hero
danieli yep yep please there's such an
interesting question
um apologies if I mispronounced your
your name stand up and tell us your
question yeah I guess it's related to
the last two questions about
um
I mean trust and abuse that we've seen
in the social networking space
um what role do you think public sector
and governments
can play in web 3 or web Point 2.0
um and so the one example is is uh
Beyond regulations basically so like a
mastodon server provided by the UK
government for example as a as a
complimentary offering in the market
yeah what what role could public sector
Alternatives play to Big Tech did you
know that there that France has a search
engine yeah it's true it's called Quant
but you might not have used it well yes
Corey I know you've thought a lot about
this yeah can public sector actually
compete so I think that if you if the
place where the public sector could
intervene to improve the quality of our
discourses by improving the quality of
our institutions so uh uh I will tell
the story as quickly as I can I promise
you at some point uh I have a chronic
pain problem a decade ago I went and saw
Harley Street Quack and he said you
should take lots of opioids for the rest
of your life because they're safer than
you think they are we have new research
and I went and did my own research to
determine that the Sackler family uh had
uh suborn their Regulators they didn't
care who they killed and they were
selling dangerous products uh with fake
research
um I was an opioid denier I was right
but epistemologically what I was doing
was no different from the people who
questioned the quality of vaccine
research they were wrong but the point
is that unless you're a cell biologist
the only thing that you can do to
evaluate the evidence is rely on what
you know about the institutions
themselves and our institutions have
been a very low quality they've been
extremely compromised they've made bad
calls we've seen this in the finance
sector we've talked about the great
financial crisis of 2008 and the
bailouts that followed we've seen lots
of other regulatory failings where uh
what was supposed to be a truth-seeking
exercise that protected the public
interest became an auction that
protected the interests of the
corporation that was the highest bidder
and it creates an epistemological chaos
where the space for people to disagree
about subjects that are important that
they themselves can adjudicate and that
creates this collapse into different
spaces about epidemiology safety
education and so on this just uh becomes
a never-ending battle you're not going
to fix it with critical thinking this is
critical thinking it's just critical
thinking gone wrong so so not so not
direct competitors but State
institutions that can actually have more
of a voice so private institutions are
never going to fill that void of of
being a public interest institution that
acts as a good faith referee to
adjudicate all the questions raised by
all the other actors in our society
that's only a thing that a public
institution can do okay and we need our
public institutions to be reformed and
to show themselves to be good actors it
takes a long time to win trust it's
really easy to lose it it's very hard to
get it back if you wanted to get there I
wouldn't start from here but this is
where we are and so we've got to start
by rebuilding our institutions as high
quality institutions that act in the
public interest in the most transparent
way possible that means doing things
like building the gold acre reports
platform for NHS data and not doing a
contract with palantir which is a
disgrace that this country is doing it
with NHS data we need to be acting in
the public interest and not in the
interests of grandies and parties and
their donors okay Amber what about you
just just quickly I would say I would
say that humans cannot be trusted and
history has shown that showed us
repeatedly in all industries that when
there is no regulation there's always
someone who's gonna mess up something
and create a crisis the trouble with
regulations is that they only happen
after the fact when you have a crisis in
health Tech when you have a crisis in
finance this is when the regulator comes
in and most of the time they come in too
hard because they're reacting to they're
reacting to a shock what I would see is
a more softer regulation that are
created hand in hand with the the
various industry but as as well with
various ethical committees because we
lack unfortunately a lot of ethic in
business but just but what about the
idea of a publicly funded Uber no
publicly a publicly funded Uber for
instance to compete with Uber well you
know what the the trouble again is that
it has been shown through histories that
public entities are perform less well
than private entities and I know I know
he's going to say something I know it I
feel him jumping
HS card begs to differ with you okay
well on that note of passionate
disagreement may I say thank you to my
fantastic panel Chris Kelly amagana
Chloe
[Applause]